hi I'm max I'll install Anam here to
show you Chronicle Google's cloud native
security analytics platform security
systems and their operators are
suffering from intense data overload we
see companies generating petabytes of
security data to sift through slowing
down the analysis and making costs
skyrocket Chronicle security analytics
solves these problems putting threat
tools detection intelligence and
forensic signals into one scalable
toolset there are six things that set
Chronicle apart from traditional
security incident and event management
products I'll walk you through each one
briefly beyond just ingesting and
storing all the data you throw at it
Chronicle also makes it useful
automatically so you can easily map
people to hosts to IPs and track down
the exact sequence of events leading to
an incident we get major benefits from
building on Google search components
Chronicle is continuously reevaluating
log activity against threat Intel when
Intel changes we automatically reapply
it against all historical activity no
other sim does this 5 login failures in
two minutes is no longer a useful threat
rule we extended yara an open standard
for malware rule writing to handle event
logs so that you can write the types of
rules to detect subtle malware attacks
another perk of using Google
infrastructure is speed even searches
against petabytes of data take less than
a second and because Chronicle is a
purpose-built security application
clients find that Tier one analysts are
much more productive most organizations
spend more time managing and tuning
their sim than they do using it for
security operations with Chronicle you
don't buy servers or storage and you
don't tune anything your team can work
on operations and analytics and protect
your business get the benefit of cloud
operations and get your analysts out of
the business of IT management
chronical rewrites the economics of Sim
we don't charge by the bite or for
ingest or for servers storage or even
compute you get a predictable fixed
price based on the size of your
organization in people one simple price
all-in and it won't break the bank
because pricing is based on heads not
bytes we want to encourage you to have
as much data as possible in Chronicle
and never get penalized because you've
gathered more logs to analyze how do we
make all that magic happen let's take a
look at the architecture the data layer
enables you to send all your security
telemetry and threat intelligence into a
private container where it is augmented
with additional threat intelligence
within your private cloud container your
security telemetry is normalized
enriched deduplicated and linked
together into a coherent timeline for
analysis and investigation finally that
data is exposed via our investigation
hunting and detection capabilities as
well as two other security products via
api's in addition to your data stored
privately in its own encrypted instance
we can bring in third-party signals and
curated internal data to enhance your
ability to detect and respond to threats
quickly there are three ways customers
are using Chronicle today extend your
current sim with high volume data that
today you throw away for example at
Google we found that DNS data is
incredibly useful for investigation and
detection but very few companies
actually capture it almost no one keeps
a year of it in their sim but we keep
all your security telemetry for an
entire year and make it instantly
accessible enhance your event detection
and response capabilities by keeping the
data for more than a week or month EDR
generates a ton of data and the vendor
struggle as much as customers to keep it
we can keep a year of it make it
searchable and correlate it to other
telemetry evolve your old and rusty Sims
their overdue for an update and cloud
technologies can make them faster and
more efficient
you can deploy Chronicle in days rather
than months and transform your security
operations metrics check out Chronicle
dot security to learn more about how we
can help you extend your current
security management platform enhance
your detection and response and evolve
from outdated systems
[Music]